[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Siebers ihn
allen guten Abend die Lage spitzt sich
weiter zu das ist so eine klassische
Überschrift der Nachrichtenagenturen die
das tägliche Leid zusammenfasst soll es
aber nicht annähernd kann die Lage in
Gaza ist bereits katastrophal dass sie
sich noch mal zuspitzt heißt konkret
200.000 Menschen im Süden von Gaza
bekommen laut UNO nicht mehr genug
Trinkwasser zwei Drittel der über 2
Millionen Einwohner sind auf der Flucht
und wissen nicht wohin Helfer können
nicht mehr auf Notrufe reagieren in
gasas größtem Krankenhaus sind laut WHO
noch rund 700 schwerkranke Patientinnen
und Patienten zu versorgen wir betteln
um eine Feuerpause sagt die
Weltgesundheitsorganisation nach
israelischer Darstellung betreibt die
Hamas in oder unter Krankenhäusern ihre
Kommandozentralen die Armee sagt sie
habe auch eine Reihe von
Regierungsgebäuden im Zentrum von Gaza
unter ihre Kontrolle gebracht Stefan
Schlösser aus Tel
Aviv triumphierende israelische Soldaten
feiern ihren Vormarsch aufgenommen im
Parlament von Gaza
Stadt vermeldet jeden Tag neue Erfolge
die Angehörigen der Geiseln warten
dagegen seit fast se Wochen auf ein
Lebenszeichen ihrer liebsten mit einem
Protestmarsch wollen sie den
öffentlichen Druck noch weiter erhöhen
innerhalb von 5 Tagen führt sie ihr Weg
von telaviv nach
Jerusalem shellemor bangt um ihren Sohn
Omer in einer Mischung aus Wut und
Verzweiflung fordert sie mehr Einsatz
der
[Musik]
Regierung ich verlange von
kabin
antwen Antworten und taten wir haben
keine Kraft mehr wir haben keine
Kraft meine Nichte ist 3 Jahre alt mein
Neffe ist 8 Jahre alt und mein Cousin
ist 12 Jahre alt meine Mutter wurde mir
genommen meine Schwester der Mann meiner
Schwester und meine Tante sie alle
wurden mir vor 39 Tagen
genommen
wie berechtigt ihre Sorge um die Geiseln
ist wurde heute in aller Grausamkeit
deutlich die 19 Jahre alte Noah massiano
ist tot verschleppt am 7 Oktober ums
Leben gekommen in Geiselhaft die Hamas
veröffentlichte ein Video und Fotos der
israelischen Soldaten die Armee hat das
offiziell
bestätigt mit diesen Bildern aus dem
Keller des rantisi Kinderkrankenhauses
in Gaza will die israelische Armee
erneut belegen dass die heramas zivile
infastruktur als Versteck nutzt zu sehen
sind unter anderem Waffen Sprengstoff
und noch
mehr wir haben auch Anzeichen gefunden
die darauf hindeuten dass die Hamas dort
Geiseln gefangen gehalten hat das
untersuchen wir aber
noch die fortdauernden Kämpfe treiben
immer mehr Menschen in den Süden Gazas
darunter sollen auch hamaskämpfer sein
hier gab es bisher nur vergleichsweise
wenige Angriffe in manchen Vierteln
wirkt das Leben normal doch zusehens
verschlechtert sich auch hier die
V Land in die stadinem eselarren
verdient etwas
Geld es gibt keinen Treibstoff
Transporte sind schwierig nur wenige
Autos oder Motorräder können fahren
Essen und Trinken sind knapp wenn es
etwas gibt ist es meist teuer vor der
einzigen Bäckerei in dieser Gegend
stehen hunderte für ein Brot
an Männer frauter und Kinder
sieinenamitenben nicht mehr als etwa 500
Packungen peterbrot am Tag produzieren
heute haben wir aber beschlossen nur
noch die halbe Menge Mehl zu nehmen so
reicht es dann für Taus
Packungen es gehört zur Grausamkeit des
Krieges das unschuldige am meisten
leiden auf beiden Seiten der Grenze die
Familie von Noah Miano hat seit heute
traurige Gewissheit dass ihre Tochter
nicht zurückkehren wird alle anderen
hoffen
weiter in Israel kämpfen also die
Angehörigen der von Hamas verschleppten
Geiseln darum das Schicksal ihr en den
Menschen im Gedächtnis zu halten den
Druck auf die Regierung hochzuhalten
auch wenn wie wir gerade gesehen haben
der Schmerz unendlich ist und die
Ungewissheit kaum zu ertragen
mittlerweile zeigen Umfragen in Israel
das oberste Priorität in der Bevölkerung
nicht mehr die Bekämpfung der Hamas ist
sondern vor allem anderen die Rückkehr
der Geiseln und auch international
bemühen sich die Angehörigen um
Unterstützung aus Berlin Christ hat
lepple
[Musik]
die Familie Babis in guten Zeiten vor
dem 7 Oktober ein junges Ehepaar mit
zwei Kindern und glücklichen
Großeltern Aufnahmen aus dem kibut Niros
etwa 2 km vom gasarstreifen entfernt gut
2500 km entfernt singt und betet die
kleine liberale Berliner Gemeinde sukot
Shalom für entführte Israelis wie jeden
Montag die Gefangenen
der
fre an diesem Abend beten für Familie
Babis die Berliner jüdische Gemeinde hat
partatenschaften für die Geißeln der
Hamas übernommen aus Israel zugeschaltet
Jossi Schneider ein
Cousin wie sie alle wissen an diesem 7
Oktober einem Feiertag wurden wir durch
Alarmsirenen geweckt nach 15 Minuten
wurde uns klar dass die H Israel
überfallen
haben seit 5 Wochen klammern sich die
Angehörigen an jeden
strohalim die letzte Nachricht die sie
schickten war sie kommen rein und dann
haben wir nichts mehr
gehört mitteoktober erste traurige
Gewissheit die Großeltern sind tot
zwei Wochen später hat die israelische
Armee ihre zwei Körper am Grenzstreifen
von Gaza gefunden wir haben sie vor di
Wochen begraben wir mussten sie anhand
von DNA identifizieren lassen sie waren
nicht mehr zu erkennen weil sie von der
Hamas verstümmelt
wurden das sind die letzten Bilder von
Mutter Shiri verzweifelt schützt sie
ihre Söhne Ariel 4 und mittlerweile 10
Monate alt Vater mit blutendem Kopf in
der Mitte wird auf einem Motorrad
gekidnappt seit 38 Tagen sind die vier
barabis in Hamas Gefangenschaft seitdem
kein Lebenszeichen einfach
[Musik]
nichts denk nach in Europa werdet wach
kümmert euch um euer Problem mit den
radikalen muslimischen
Gruppen was bleibt nach fast se Wochen
Ungewissheit hoffen auf ein Wunder mehr
nicht
oder wie die israelische
Kinderbuchautorin sag em träumt wie wäre
eine Welt ohne Angst in den Augen von
Kindern der nostkrieg hat folgen weit
über den Nahen Osten hinaus die
Gründerin der Klimabewegung Fridays for
future erregt Aufsehen mit Appellen bei
denen sie sich weniger als
klimaaktivistin zeigt denn als Kämpferin
für die Sache der Palästinenser und
dabei auch in den eigenen Reihen vor
allem in deutsland einiges an Kritik und
Widerspruch bekommt Greta tberg
polarisiert ja bereits länger jetzt aber
auch innerhalb ihrer Bewegung eine
weltweite influencerin mit aber
Millionen Followern die sich die Frage
gefallen lassen muss für was sie ihren
Einfluss nutzt und warum sie Fridays for
future auf diese Weise spaltet wi
hcher sie versuchen weiterzumachen die
Fridays for future hier in Kel und
anderenorts in deut
wie man das so macht wenn man im Sturm
steht im Sturm der Entrüstung und
Empörung ich fin es einfach nur wichtig
dass letztendlich irgendwie um die Sache
geht und dabei auch bleibt dass wir
einfach also dass die Klimakrise da ist
und dass wir halt was machen müssen beim
Klima bleiben allein das geht nicht mehr
weil Krieg ist und Greta Thunberg sich
vor fast 15 Millionen Followern auf
Instagram öffentlich positioniert gegen
Israel für Gaza vorgestern in Amsterdam
ergreift sie vor 85000 Menschen
wiederpartei für die Palästinenser bis
ein Demonstrant versucht ihr das Wort zu
entreißen er will übers Klima reden
nicht über Palästina ihre
Antwort es gibt keine Klimagerechtigkeit
auf besetztem Land Greta tunberg
skandiert im Chor und spaltet
gleichzeitig doch die eigenen Leute
Greta hat durch ihre nichtbenennung von
jüdischem Leid sehr viele Menschen
verletzt und ich denke dass es gerade
deswegen wichtig ist dass wir in
Deutschland immer wieder deutlich machen
dass wir für den Schutz von jüdischem
Leben stehen zum Glück ist die Bewegung
in Deutschland mittlerweile über Greta
Thunberg hinausgewachsen und kann
unabhängig von ihr agieren sich
unabhängig machen man würde Luisa
Neubauer gerne fragen wie das gehen soll
Interviews gibt sie kaum der politische
Druck nach Distanzierung enorm dazu
gehört dann auch dass sich freil for
future in Deutschland klar von der
internationalen Bewegung nicht nur
distanziert sondern davon entfernt
auflöst bzw eben
alle strenge kappt es geht frei des
verfüer nicht um die Rettung der Welt
sondern um die Delegitimierung und
einigen auch um die Auslöschung Israels
wer sich jetzt noch hinter dem Label
Fridays for Futer versammelt der macht
sich mit Hamas Terroristen gemein durch
solche Kritik wächst in der klimaszene
eine Sorge die der
Instrumentalisierung wir haben gerade in
den jüngsten Diskussionen auch bei der
Energiewende in Deutschland gesehen dass
die widerständem dagegen sind und da
gibt es Interessensgruppen aus sei
politischer Natur oder auch von
Unternehmen die natürlich froh sind wenn
der Klimaschutz und die Klimaschutz
Organisationen geschwächt werden und
insofern ist das natürlich gefundenes
Fressen auch international sind die
Deutschen Fridays in der Defensive und
in der Minderheit man merkt eben dass
der Spagat der in den letzten Jahren
noch so einigermaßen funktioniert hat
nämlich zum deutschen Establishment
sprechen aber gleichzeitig solidarisch
sein mit den Bewegungen im globalen
Süden dass das jetzt aufbricht und das
wird sehr schwer zu kitten sein vor
allem mit ihr die heute ein anderes
Gesicht
zeigt später im heute journal Update ein
Gespräch zum Thema mit dem Präsidenten
der Deutsch-Israelischen Gesellschaft
und jenseits der greeta Thunberg
Diskussion bleibt das Grundthema
außerordentlich drängend der UNO
Generalsekretär warnt heute erneut die
Welt schafft es nicht die Klimakrise in
den Griff zu
bekommen so wir gucken jetzt auf weitere
wichtige Nachrichten von diesem Dienstag
haben wir heute richtig mit dir Hanna
bahnreisende müssen sich ab morgen Abend
auf Zugausfälle und Verspätungen
einstellen die lockführergewerkschaft
GDL hat ab 22 Uhr zu Streiks aufgerufen
die bis Donnerstagabend andauern sollen
die Bahn kritisiert den geplanten Streik
während der laufenden Verhandlungen als
Unding bereits zum Auftakt habe der
Konzern ein 11% Angebot auf den Tisch
gelegt die GDL fordert dagegen
555 € mehr im Monat und für
Schichtarbeiter eine kürzere
Wochenarbeitszeit ohne
Lohnkürzungen die EU
verteidigungsministerinnen und Minister
haben heute über weitere Militärhilfen
für die Ukraine beraten
Bundesverteidigungsminister Pistorius
bestätigte am Rande des Treffens dass
die Deutschen Hilfen von vier auf 8
Milliarden Euro verdoppelt werden sollen
zudem äußerte er sich zum Ziel der EU
bis zum nächsten Frühjahr eine Million
Artilleriegeschosse an die Ukraine zu
liefern dies werde nicht erreicht sagte
Pistorius die Produktion müsse
hochgefahren
werden internationale Recherchen mit
zdfbeteiligung haben aufgedeckt dass
russische Oligarchen das EU-Land Zypern
nutzen um Sanktionen zu umgehen und über
Briefkastenfirmen ihr Geld zu mehren
grundlage sind mehr als dreieinhalb
Millionen geliegte Dokumente darin
taucht auch der der preisgekrönte
deutsche tvjournalist und russlandexerte
Hubert Seipel auf er soll für ein
Buchprojekt über Putin 600.000 € von
einem mittlerweile sanktionierten
russischen Oligarchen erhalten haben
Seipel hat dies eingeräumt die Zahlungen
hätten jedoch keinen Einfluss auf den
Inhalt seiner Bücher
gehabt als erstes Bundesland in
Deutschland will Bayern eine Bezahlkarte
für Asylbewerber einführen das hat das
bayerische Kabinett beschlossen
flüchtete sollen nach den Plänen bereits
ab dem Frühjahr 2024 weitestgehend kein
Bargeld mehr vom stat erhalten sondern
stattdessen mit der Bezahlkarte
einkaufen können Überweisungen in die
Heimat oder Onlinekäufe sollen dann
nicht mehr möglich
sein landminenen Blindgänger und
Munitionsreste haben im vergangenen Jahr
erneut tausende Menschen verletzt oder
getötet das erklärte die internationale
Kampagne zum Verbot von landminenen laut
Bericht von verloren mehr als
1660 Menschen ihr Leben durch die
Sprengkörper über 3000 hätten
Verletzungen davon getragen in den
meisten Fällen habe es Zivilisten
getroffen die Hälfte davon seinen Kinder
gewesen den Großteil der Opfer gab es in
Syrien und der
Ukraine die Linke als Partei ist nicht
tot aber ihre Bundes Bundestagsfraktion
ist auch nicht mehr am Leben sie hat
heute entschieden sich selbst aufzulösen
zuletzt hatte die Linke 38 Abgeordnete
im Parlament die machen jetzt getrennt
weiter die einen als restlinke sozusagen
und die anderen als Anhänger eines neuen
Bündnisses um Sarah Wagenknecht auf
jeden Fall also als Konkurrenten damit
geht ein Kapitel zu Ende das 2005
begonnen hatte die Linken Spitzenleute
versuchen das heute als neustat zu
verkaufen Christian hübscher mit mehr
dazu SAR Wagenknecht kommt heute nicht
um das fraktionsende mit zu schließen
wohl aber vier ihrer Mitstreiter die
Spaltung sichtbar und greifbar noch
bevor Dietmar barartsch der ewige
Fraktionsvorsitzende der immer vor der
Spaltung gewarnt hatte es verkündet
fraktionsaus ist an Nikolaus die
Linksfraktion hat eben eine Entscheidung
getroffen und zwar die Entscheidung dass
wir die Auflösung der Fraktion zum 6.12
diesen Jahres einleiten werden ist es
heute für uns alle kein schöner Tag aber
es ist gleich zetig die Chance für einen
Aufbruch ihr Weggang hatte den
endgültigen Bruch besiegelt Sarah
Wagenknecht die sich mit eigener Partei
selbstständig machen will dass sich eine
Fraktion mitten in der Legislatur selbst
auflöst das gab es noch nie die Linke
zerfällt in zwei Gruppen die Linke
Gruppe und die Gruppe Wagenknecht und
der Kampf um die einzig wahre Linke hat
spätestens heute begonnen wir sind die
einzige relevante linke Partei in
Deutschland und in diesem Sinne werden
wir unsere Arbeit im Bundestag
selbstverständlich fortsetzen en und
alles daran setzen dass wir 2025
gestärkt selbstverständlich als Fraktion
in den Bundestag wieder einziehen das
halte ich für eher unrealistig weil wenn
eine Partei auf einem
abwärtsgang sich befindet ist die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass man wieder nach
oben kommt und mit neuer Kraft der
Bevölkerung sich gegenüberstellt eher
schwach ausgeprägt weil der Zyklus in
dem sich augenblicklich Politik bewegt
der wartet nicht auf eine
linksparteialterart der Bundestag muss
entscheiden wie er mit den beiden
Gruppen umgeht welche Rechte sie
bekommen wie viel Geld ihnen noch
zusteht wer künftig wo sitzt im
Parlament einer der beiden Liquidatoren
ist er Thomas Westfall bisher Büroleiter
des Vorstands er muss nun 108
Mitarbeitern kündigen das werden also
alle Sachen Vermögenswerte der Fraktion
werden aufgenommen und diese müssen dann
so bis zum Schluss bis also nichts mehr
übrig ist von der Fraktion also keine
Technik und auch die Mitarbeiterinnen
und Mitarbeiter dann so ihre Kündigung
erhalten haben dass diese Liquidation
dann so erfolgt dass es am Ende
sozusagen bei bei Null steht Streit
könnte es noch über diese Personalie
geben was wird aus Petra Pau Petra Pau
sitzt als
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin oben im
Präsidium und soll da anscheinend noch
zwei weitere Jahre sitzen obwohl sie
überhaupt gar keinen Fraktionsstatus
mehr hat sie ist ja vom gesamten Haus
gewählt worden also mit einer wältigen
Mehrheit übrigens und ich glaube dass
Sie über alle Parteigrenzen weg also bis
auf eine Partei doch allseits eine so
große Reputation erlebt dass das glaube
ich überhaupt gar nicht zur Disposition
steht die Linke sei nicht tot beteuert
Dietmar Bartsch heute immer wieder für
manchen aber endet wohl hier ein
Lebenswerk ja das sollte man noch
historisch gerade zuu einordnen solche
Liquidationen einer Fraktion gab es
bisher nur nach Wahlniederlagen jetzt
also zum ersten Mal während der
laufenden Legislatur guten Abend Diana
Zimmermann wie einschneidend ist denn
das für die Linke jetzt das ist sehr
einschneidend Dietmar Berch versuchte
zwar heute ein bisschen die historische
Dimension klein zu reden indem er immer
wieder davon sprach das sei die Chance
für einen Neuanfang was er damit meinte
ist dass nach der Trennung von Sarah
Wagenknecht oder mehr nach der Trennung
die Sara Wagenknecht vorgenommen hat der
innerparteiliche Streit nun aufen konnte
dass man sich nun wieder konzentrieren
könnte auf die Themen die ursprünglich
die Linken waren nämlich die der
sozialen Gerechtigkeit und den Osten so
sagte dietm warst das aber auch wenn die
Linke in Zukunft den Status als
parlamentarische Gruppe im Bundestag
haben sollte so hat sie doch weniger
Rechte weniger Geld und eine deutlich
kleinere Bühne und das Land das SE
zeigen die Umfragen ja ziemlich deutlich
ist nach rechts gerückt die
Wahrscheinlichkeit also dass die Linke
da ein großes Comeback feiert ist gering
und wenn die mal Barsch vor seinen
bedröppelten Abgeordneten sagt die Linke
ist nicht tot dann klingt das doch eher
nach Beschwörung und was heißt das ganz
konkret für die künftige Diskussion dann
im Parlament zweimal linke Konkurrenz
gleich mehr Aufmerksamkeit oder doch
eher Stiefmütterchen da
sein ich glaube dass linke Diskussionen
weniger Aufmerksamkeit bekommen werden
es ist ja schon mal so dass viele
anzweifeln dass das Bündnis Sara
Wagenknecht überhaupt eine linke Partei
im eigentlichen Sinne genannt werden
kann in der Sozialpolitik ja in der
Migrationspolitik eindeutig nein dann
zieht dar Wagenknecht ja grundsätzlich
sehr viel Aufmerksamkeit auf sich viel
Raum für die Linke wird er wohl nicht
bleiben und
interessant finde ich eigentlich eher zu
beobachten wie sich die zwei
Protestparteien die wir dann im
Bundestag haben zueinander verhalten
werden nämlich das Bündnis Saher
Wagenknecht und die
AFD interessant auch dass wir das heute
Abend hier so markiert haben herzlich
herlichen dank Diana nach
Berlin im kommenden Jahr soll es 44
Staaten dieser Welt in 44 Staaten dieser
Welt nationale Wahlen geben darunter in
den USA die große fakeemchine läuft sich
bereits warm um zu denunzieren zu
täuschen zu beeinflussen und darauf zu
setzen dass zumindest ein Gutteil der
Menschheit die in immer mehr
internetcilips Videos Bildern ertrinkt
es nicht merkt schon jetzt sind ständig
neue künstlich generierte Beispiele
dafür im Umlauf die echt aussehen aber
nicht echt sind und vor allem eins
erreichen dass wir unsere reale Welt von
der künstlichen kaum noch unterscheiden
können weil diese Technologie mit
riesigen öffentlich verfügbaren
Datenmengen trainiert wird sind all die
besonders betroffen die in der
Öffentlichkeit stehen Politikerinnen und
Fernsehmoderatoren etwa wie jetzt
aktuell die Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
Tagesschau die sich mit gefaken Stimmen
herumschlagen
sind wir überhaupt darauf vorbereitet
wie viel künstliches bereits Realität
ist und was da noch auf uns zukommt
Christian von Rechenberg ist dem
nachgegangen ich SLE kurz mal was
erzählen 30 Sekunden mehr nicht Bart
mich mein Kollege Ralf Benz aus der
Wissenschaftsredaktion und nahm das
ganze
auf mein kleiner grüner Kaktus der stuen
am das kleine Video schickt er an eine
KI und 20 Minuten spter schickt die KI
etwas Unglaubliches zurück es gibt's
nicht siehst du doch meine Stimme deine
Stimme
geklont übersetzt und lippensynchron auf
dich drauf
gesetzt ich würde sagen das ist der sind
die Anfänge von generativer KI wir
werden da in Zukunft noch viel viel mehr
davon sehen viel viel perfekter viel
viel besser
der Anfang und der hat schon in sich
zwei oder drei Stichworte genügen und
künstliche Intelligenz spuckt ganze
Filme aus wie diesen
balloons sogar eine Skizze reicht aus
etwa für einen
blubberblasengenerator und die KI baut
daraus eine fertige
Webseite und dieser Roboterhund
kommuniziert dank
KI klug wie ein Mensch muss ich das mal
klar machen dies diese K Systeme
beherrschen ja jetzt Sprache und wenn
man Sprache beherrscht dann beherrscht
man das universelle Kommunikationsmittel
zwischen Menschen und dadurch wird sich
sehr sehr viel verändern und zwar Rasen
schnell schneller als es die Entwickler
je gedacht hätten ausgerechnet darauf
sagt die Expertin sind wir nicht gut
vorbereitet also in vielen grämien z.B
in der Politik die Sachen entscheiden
bezüglich Technik oder Digitalisierung
gibt es teilweise ein ein grotesk
geringen Technik Sachverstand und das
ist natürlich eine Katastrophe nämlich
dann wenn KI Menschen manipulieren soll
durch Fakes Beispiele gibt's viele etwa
der geklonte Moderator Christian sieers
der plötzlich für eine Geldanlage
Werbung macht gestützten anlageplattform
die bereits Millionen von Deutschen
Bürgern zur Verfügung steht also wenn
ich es beiläufig mir anschaue dann ist
die Qualität mit Sicherheit gut genug
dass man schon täuschende Veränderungen
oder Manipulation durchführen kann für
professionelle fakejäger wie Martin
Steinebach wird die Arbeit immer
anspruchsvoller es gibt erste Ansätze KI
zu kennzeichnen Sie mit ebenfalls KI
gestützter Software zu erkennen wie
gesagt Ansätze heutzutage wird man
eigentlich immer eine Kombination aus
einem Computersystem und einem
menschlichen Entscheider brauchen also
das ein System alleine schon
Entscheidungen trifft ist das ganze ein
deepfake oder nicht ist das eine
Fälschung oder nicht da ist man noch
weit entfernt die Politik reagiert erste
Staaten wie die USA wollen neue
ki-prukte erst testen bevor sie auf den
Markt kommen und die EU plant eine
Regulierung der KI mittels verschiedene
Risikostufen doch ein Problem bleibt wir
haben es hier gerade mit Systemen zu tun
die sich extrem schnell entwickeln die
Systeme von heute werden in 5 Jahren
schon im Museum stehen da ist natürlich
extrem schwer Regelwerke zu machen
dennoch Bast ist überzeugt dass die
guten das Rennen gewinnen werden mit
Hilfe von KI die KI erkennt und stoppt
und zur Not sagt auch Ralf kann man KI
jederzeit den Stecker ziehen solange sie
noch Strom braucht ja das Thema wird uns
in Atem halten auch weil die umgekehrte
Frage ebenso drängend ist wenn alles
potenziell gefälscht sein könnte wie
viel Raum bleibt da noch für
Fakten so bei uns jetzt noch mal Fakten
mit dir Hanna und einem weiteren
Zukunftsthema die Pläne für ein
wasserstoffleitungsnetz in Deutschland
werden immer konkreter laut
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Harbeck soll
es insgesamt 9700 km lang werden und so
unter anderem Industrie und Kraftwerke
versorgen Stephanie Barrett heute wurden
die Pläne vorgestellt wie sehen sie aus
also die Zukunftspläne für den politisch
gewünschten wasserstoffhochlauf sehen
bereits in nur knapp 10 Jahren ein
deutschlandweites pipelineenetz von rund
10.000 km vor das dann Häfen
Industriegebiete Speicher und Kraftwerke
verbindet dabei sollen 60% der
vorhandenen erdgasröhren umgerüstet der
Rest neu gebaut werden die im deutschen
Gasnetz Verwandten Stahlrohrleitungen
sind dabei gasexperten zufolge auch für
den Transport von Wasserstoff geeignet
die Speicher fehlen dagegen noch in der
Planung denn Gasspeicher dürfen nicht
einfach umgewidmet werden weil sie auf
Jahre noch unverzichtbar sein werden und
der Netzausbau ist mit der mit sehr
hohen und langfristigen Investitionen
verbunden die Kosten von rund 20
Milliarden EUR für das Kernnetz soll
zwar die Privatwirtschaft übernehmen da
aber in den ersten Jahren nur wenige
Nutzer erwartet werden wird auch hier
der Bund die Finanzierung absichern und
spätere kostenlücken abdecken
Wasserstoff gilt ja als Hoffnungsträger
der Energiewende warum genau ja
Wasserstoff möglichst grüner erzeugt aus
Wind und Solarstrom gilt eben als
klimaneutraler Brennstoff der Zukunft
und ist zentraler Baustein der deutschen
Energiewende die wasserstoffnutzung ist
allerdings hier zuande sehr teuer mehr
als die Hälfte müsste Deutschland
nämlich importieren also noch viel
Zukunftsmusik die mit vielen
Fragezeichen versehen ist vielen Dank
Stefanie für deine
Einschätzung Kirche und Religiosität
verlieren weiter an Bedeutung das zeigt
eine Untersuchung der Evangelischen
Kirche in Deutschland in der Menschen
mit und ohne Konfession befragt worden
sind demnach hat Religion für fast acht
von zehn Befragten überhaupt keine oder
nur wenig nicht Bedeutung und auch das
Vertrauen in die Institution ist gering
dennoch erwartet eine deutliche Mehrheit
der Befragten von der Kirche
gesellschaftliches Engagement z.B durch
den Einsatz für
geflüchtete jetzt zu einer
Unwetterwarnung des Deutschen
Wetterdienstes vor ergiebigem Dauerregen
betroffen sind Teile von Bayern und von
Baden-Württemberg in der Karibik
entsteht das erste Schutzgebiet für
potwale die Regierung von Dominika
erklärte man habe für die gefährdeten
meersäuger vor der Insel ein rund 800
quadrkm großes Gebiet vorgesehen dort
leben schätzungsweise noch bis zu 500
Pottwale werden vor allem von Schiffen
und Netzen bedroht das Schutzgebiet soll
auch die ausbereitung von Plankton
fordern das laut Biologen große Mengen
an CO2
bendet und mit dieser Nachricht sagen
wir ganz herzlichen Dank für Ihr
Interesse heute und gegen 015 Uhr gibt's
dann unser heute journal Update mit
nasan göckdem mir von uns allen hier an
sie einen angenehmen Abend tschüss
[Applaus]
[Musik]
tschüss guten Abend große
Temperaturunterschiede gibt es zurzeit
in Europa winterlich ist es im Norden
Skandinaviens mit min 10° auf den
Kanaren da gab es heute noch mal 30°.
wir liegen damit 10 15° in der Mitte und
es war einiges los stürmisch war es im
Norden und auf den Bergen intensiven
Dauerregen gab es weiter im Süden die
beiden zugehörigen Tiefs allerdings
verlieren bis morgen ihren Einfluss auf
uns da kommt schon das nächste Tief aber
mit weniger Regen und ein Zwischenhoch
sorgt dann auch ab Donnerstag für
ruhigeres Wetter eine Menge geregnet hat
es seit Sonntag vor allem im
Berchtesgarden Land im Alge und im
Schwarzwald da waren das 50 bis 100 l
meist auf den Quadratmeter punktuell so
z.B auf der krunkelbachhütte im
Schwarzwald sogar 168 l pro Quadrat und
heute Nacht kommt in genau diesen
Regionen noch mal 10 bis 20 ler dazu
dazu wird der Wind stürmisch aus
westlichen Richtungen auf den Bergen
sind wäre sturmböhen möglich Richtung
Norden lassen Schauer und kurze Gewitter
in der zweiten Nachthälfte nach es
lockert auf dann sinken die Temperaturen
auf 3° sonst bleiben sie teils bei 9°.
morgen liegen die Höchstwerte zwischen
7° in Schleswig-Holstein und 13° entlang
des Rheins dazu gibt's die Warmfront mit
vielen Wolken und Regen zwischen dem
Erzgebirge und der Nordsee sonst ziehen
immer wieder Schauer und kurze Gewitter
ged durch es gibt aber auch trockene
teilss sonnige Phasen bei einem starken
westlichen Wind im Süden mit sturmböhnen
auf den Bergen ab Donnerstag kommt dann
das zwischenoch es wird etwas ruhiger am
Freitag wieder kühler und stürmischer
das nächste Wochenende wird dann aber
schon wieder von Westen milder und damit
tschüss